Relief printmaking, the
first print process invented
had its origins in seals
in China around 255 B.C.
If you think of relief
printmaking as a stamp,
which is a very basic transfer of an image
from one surface to another.
That is the initial concept
of relief printmaking.
The image area is raised,
whereas the non-image area is lowered.
So if you think of a plank of wood
and you carve away the white areas,
what is raised would
become the image area.
One of the modern inventions, linoleum,
for what we call a
linocut or linoleum cut,
provided artists with the opportunity
of working on the material in
a way that was new and unique.
Relief printmaking, as the
earliest form of printmaking,
is still the most accessible
form of printmaking.
Because a press is not
required to transfer the image
from the block to paper, it allows artists
just about anywhere in the world
who have access to a
small amount of materials,
whether they be wood or linoleum,
and a small amount of ink, to
be able to create an image.
Artists like relief printmaking
because it affords them
the opportunity to have a
very direct low-tech way
of working to produce bold graphic images
with strong blacks as well
as fine detailed lines.
Its accessibility allows for a variety of
marks and sensibilities, both
abstract and representational,
both things that involve
text as well as images.